welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight that is eight five five at
two thirty six thirty to twenty eight
Tyler in Michigan you're on the bench
Shapiro she'll go for Tyler I just want
to apologize for our governor he doesn't
really speak for all of us let me just
leave it to myself the recent reports
I've seen from you guys daily lighter
and just basically online has been put
in thirty on test I'm just wondering as
the conservative base the Republican
base what can we do to just kind of whip
up our people to get out there and just
make sure that the old twenty this
doesn't happen and well you know I think
that the biggest thing is that we have
to constantly be exposing his old
remarks to scrutiny I mean the fact is
his old remarks are the same as his new
remarks because he has never changed
according to his own dick taught he has
never changed his philosophy has never
changed here's the thing I've been in
politics since I was 17 years old and
I've changed my opinions on a wide
variety of things in fact you can find
an entire list online of things that I
have said that I think are dumb and I
have said here is why I changed my
opinion because this is a dumb thing to
say and here's why I think it was a dumb
thing to say Bernie Sanders has never
changed a single one of his old commie
opinions and now he wants us to just
believe that he has shifted into sort of
being a normal mainstream Northern
European Democratic Socialist as opposed
to like a full-scale socialist even the
Democratic Socialist in northern Europe
by the way acknowledged the capitalism
is a wonderful thing they just call
themselves socialists for purposes of
broadening the social safety net which
means that basically bernie is the same
as Hillary Clinton see here's the dirty
here's the problem for Bernie Bernie
likes to say that he is a socialist as
opposed to those other Democrats who are
Democrats but then when you get him to
actually talk about his plans they are
the same as all the other Democrats so
what distinguishes him just the word
socialist so what does it mean nobody
actually asked Bernie what it means
instead he just elides the question by
saying things like well if by socialism
what you mean is that I want all people
to have great housing and a hamburger
and of course all my social no that's
not what I mean Bernie I mean what do
you do you mean public ownership over
the mechanisms of production is that
what you mean right that is the
definition of socialism and and he won't
answer that question so the thing we
have to make sure of is that people
understand how much of a threat bernie
is now people you know are not
politically informed so they tend to buy
into whatever they hear and the fact
that Bernie has a very strong ground
game
the fact that he's been able to obscure
his own radicalism and also the fact
that he's super old so he doesn't appear
threatening in the same way that Ron
Paul didn't appear you know threatening
to the left because Ron Paul was old
it's the same sort of thing with Bernie
but bernie is not a cute and cuddly old
dude bernie is a dangerous socialist who
has sided with every evil regime of the
last half century so you know we need to
make that clear we need to try it out
victims of those regimes we need to make
obvious that his plans involve you
losing your health insurance like all
the facts need to be brought to light
and needs to be done in a way where it
isn't just Trump you know talking about
how Bernie has crazy hair or how
Bernie's a weirdo or something it's got
to be like an actual on-the-ground
effort to just explain who Bernie is
coming from Michigan I know he's somehow
what our primary back 2016 but it
doesn't make sense to me considering
just our manufacturing roots there you
would think that residents that live
here wasn't one just up it was
essentially just full-blown and
communism run in the state I mean we're
already kind of having an issue with
their governor but another story primary
day though so so you know in Michigan I
think what happened there is that Bernie
was the only person running in the last
primary who was anti free trade and
there there is a move in Michigan
particularly to suggest that the reason
the manufacturing jobs have left
Michigan is because of government
failures in the trading sir which is why
Trump did really well in Michigan right
so I think that Bernie on that score did
fairly well also obviously Bernie did
very well among sort of the industrial
base or the Michael Moore areas of
Michigan overall if Bernie runs against
Trump in Michigan is that going to go
well for Bernie I have serious doubts
that's gonna go great for Bernie in a
lot of the swing states in Michigan in
Pennsylvania in Wisconsin Wisconsin is
his best hope cuz Wisconsin actually
does have a fairly long socialist
history going back to Robert La Follette
but I don't think that you're going to
see Bernie succeed well in Michigan
really appreciate the call Tyler let's
see Matthew in Montreal Canada you're on
the bench Bureau should I go for a
mantra go for a Matthew hi how are you
then thank you for taking my calls
my big concern and this is what I hear
from multiple people some people say
that Bernie Sanders if he's the
Democratic nominee he's just going to
yeah Trump is just going to run through
him in the electoral college and then
some others say that if he's the nominee
it's going to become
biggest challenge I just want to know
what your take on this is so I think
that just my so there's my head my heart
and I'm sort of divided to be honest
with you in my head Burnie is is the
easiest nominee to be because he's the
most radical he provides the most cannon
fodder for Trump there's just tons of
material on him the Apple on him is the
easiest thing in the entire world on the
other hand Bernie does have the passion
of a small group of people in the
passion of a small group of people when
juxtaposed to Trump's generalized
unpopularity at least up to this point
is not is not bad right you do need some
passion to get to the polls as Hillary
Clinton demonstrated in 2016 when she
had not so my heart says that Bernie's
dangerous my head says that he is the
least dangerous candidate I think that I
will go with my head that Bernie would
be the easiest to beat but I am the most
afraid of Bernie as president because he
is the most radical because he's an
insane communist and so the idea of
having that as president I've said this
before I would rather have Bernie I'd
rather have Biden as the Democratic
nominee as a conservative I'd rather
Biden as the Democratic nominee with a
45% shot at the presidency than Bernie
as the nominee with a 40% shot at the
presidency I think both of them are
unlikely to become president but the
risk of burning a being president is
significantly higher than the risk of
Biden being president because Biden is a
dead person and Bernie isn't is an
actual live communist which is a pretty
scary thing to be Matthew I appreciate
the call and good luck up there in
Canada my friend all righty well we will
be back in just a moment and we'll bring
you the latest on Trump State of the
Union the blowback to the State of the
Union Nancy Pelosi demonstrating that
she is just as childish as anybody else
in Congress not the adult in the room
plus we'll get to the latest from the
Iowa caucuses results still trickling in
and there will be for the next several
years this is the Ben Shapiro show